[Music]  it is ordered adjudged and decreed that  Walter McMillian is to face death by  electrocution it's my dad sir sit down  young man John would you sit down they  do nothing wrong please judge hold on  one second I won't say it again  sit down not even you're gonna kill my  dad for no reason  they convicted an innocent man I was  always taught to fight for the people  who need to help me most you don't know  what it is yeah  man got no evidence how many of you all  were with Walter that morning you ain't  quit miss no sir we all which I want my  son growing no when his mom stopped  doing what was right because she was  scared I think we could build a case  strong I'll have to bring him home and  I'm not gonna stop until I've done that  present you do it  [Applause]  your life is still meaningful and I'm  gonna do everything possible to keep  definitely taking in  [Music]  you